una apuesta continental para hacer
frente a una creciente crisis migratoria
los líderes de naciones de américa del
norte del sur y centroamérica se
reunieron en los ángeles esta semana
durante la cumbre de las américas el
tema central de este año fue la
migración el gobierno de joe biden
impulsó la adopción de una hoja de ruta
para los países de acogida y tránsito de
los migrantes y refugiados en la región
entonces con esta declaración estamos
transformando nuestro enfoque de la
gestión de la migración en las américas
cada uno de nosotros está firmando
compromisos que reconocen los desafíos
que todos compartimos y la
responsabilidad de los impactos de todas
nuestras naciones grace jones al final
20 de las 35 naciones del continente
firmaron y byd en espera que haya más
apoyos en el futuro la declaración de
los ángeles se basa en cuatro pilares
vías legales para los trabajadores
extranjeros ayuda a las comunidades que
acogen a los migrantes una gestión más
humana de las fronteras y respuestas
coordinadas de emergencia la decisión de
washington de excluir a venezuela cuba y
nicaragua
basándose en prácticas antidemocráticas
llegó a varios países entre ellos el
vecino directo de estados unidos-méxico
a enviar al canciller marcelo ebrard en
reemplazo del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador
tenemos ahora mismo unos resultados de
la cumbre que son muy positivos desde
nuestro punto de vista desde el punto de
vista
sin embargo méxico alabó el resultado
final la política de migración de
washington se ha centrado durante mucho
tiempo a contener la migración irregular
a través de su frontera sur pero en los
últimos años se ha producido un fenómeno
creciente en todo el hemisferio
occidental ya que millones de
venezolanos huyen del colapso económico
hacia los países vecinos colombia
ecuador y perú cientos de miles de
nicaragüenses son empujados por la
persecución política hacia costa rica y
un número incalculable de
centroamericanos se refugian de la
violencia de las pandillas trasladándose
a méxico oa estados unidos